[Music]
um thank you for coming out in this
brain um I it was brought to my
attention that some of the Flyers said
7:30 so that's the only reason we we're
waiting just a little while um some
people may show up um thank you guys for
coming um I know it's a very tough uh
difficult uh topic to talk about but it
is important very urgent a lot of people
understand it a lot of people don't a
lot of people think they understand it
um a lot of people don't think they
understand it but um that gives us more
the reason to talk about it so I'm just
going to um say a few words before um in
a little slideshow and then I'll be
introducing our um speaker n Darwish in
a little bit so um on this
campus have it prepared um on this
campus longtime friendships and uh have
been ended new friendships are
questionable and uh the campus in
Philadelphia socialist and Islamic
organizations are appalled and offended
because this organization Temple
University purpose dares to bring Islam
and Sharia LA to to the arena of
discussion thought and
question in Afghan an Iran and other
Middle Eastern countries gays women
Christians and Jews among other
minorities are being murdered and
tortured to death in the name of Islam
according to the ways of Muhammad and
sharah it is perplexing that our
decision uh to bring to attention and
expose these atrocities that otherwise
are hidden from VI behind the wall of
political correctness and the
counterproductive notion of mul
multiculturalism is met with such anger
and
opposition uh people are dying people
are being discriminated legitimately
discri discriminated they are being
oppressed their freedom of speech is
punished their freedom of religion is
denied and their sense of personal
personal identity is
lost um it is lost in assessible of an
evil emptiness uh someone could say that
this evil emptiness is Sharia La um and
that Sharia La is the danger it is the
perpetrator not the Savior not the
solution
so why is Temple University purpose
islamophobic why am I a racist why am I
the
bigot I'm not and we're
not uh questioning Islam under equal
scrutiny as any other religion is
neither islamophobic nor
bigoted however it is dangerous Tabu and
an instant means by which to assassinate
someone's character or a group's
credibility
this organization for example Temple
University purpose we have we have the
most clearly inclusive mission that
defense diversity with the sole goal of
enhancing one's understanding of others
through acquiring knowledge for more
from more than one angle and from more
than one
source and that is
the and that is the major and that is
what the majority of Campus does not
like the fact alone the Temple
University purpose extends um its for to
points of view outside of the politic
correct politically correct
accessible on which the accepted
politically correct topics float uh
makes Temple University purpose the
perfect most sought-after Target for
character assassination and credibility
assassination standing up for the rights
of those with no voice is no crime of
racism or bigotry doing so however is a
responsibility a responsibility that we
proudly take on those who oppose those
questioning the questioning of and the
proposing and propos closing the
shutting down of events regarding
anything Islam themselves are embracing
the totalitarian mentality adhere to
under Sharia so they are already
controlled slaves and they have no
idea more than often every semester the
feminists on campus or the Socialists
both from the C the campus chapters and
the City of Philadelphia along with a
number of members of the Islamic
organizations on this
campus criticize us for not including or
inviting the MSA to participate in joint
events
and yes that is a valid
criticism however it is an incorrect
misinformed one since the spring of 2010
I have personally reached out to the MSA
I have done little things from big
sales uh and they we have been rejected
uh they have showed no
interest and
uh this and this fall uh this fall I
reached out to the current president to
work with purpose on a joint event where
both organizations brought a speaker of
their
choice but they did not approve of our
speaker because he criticized Islam I
thought to myself what kind of speaker
do they want what will ever be what will
ever be an acceptable speaker is that
acceptable speaker someone that that
agrees with someone uh with the MSA with
um with the MSA on everything that they
think everything that they feel so the
president of the MSA once told me that
um regarding um our choice of speaker
the style of the speaker that we um that
we invite that that wasn't that
etiquette U of dialogue and you know I
think it's appropriate to say back to
the MSA president that it's not the eate
of dialogue to not join in dialogue
simply because you disagree with the
point of view um and the style of speak
of the of the opposing view uh that the
speaker holds the Socialists argument is
always that it is not the responsibility
to help us provide the
speaker um that we would otherwise have
asked the MS to invite sure that is a
valid argument as well if we allotted
more if we were allotted more money per
semester it would be easier but we are
just one organization and we are given
two $2,500 to create one or two events
with speakers now taking into account
that we have five or six Islamic
organizations on campus alone all of
them uh which are pretty are made up of
pretty much the same students
um however under differently named
Islamic organizations they are able to
get the at the very least
$12,500 up to
$15,000 as opposed to the $2,500 that we
get and what is worst and most
hypocritical of those that criticize us
is when one asks where are the human
rights groups on this campus when it
comes to the human rights and the human
crimes Cent Sharia law where are the
feminists where are the gay rights
groups and most important where are
those five to six Islamic organizations
on this campus now why aren't they
talking about the oppressive human
rights conditions and crimes under
Sharia well they are earlier today at
4:00 the MSA had an event on Sharia as
well and I can assure you that this
event what this event was to counter us
and talk about the beauty and wonder of
Islam and sure um there are beautiful
things that they consider um in Islam
however none of the ugly realistic
things um that happen under Sharia are
discussed and we try to plan again this
past
um at the end of the semester we tried
again to to have an event with them and
we went through two speakers that they
rejected they wanted nothing and so we
were fortunate to have uh n Darwish uh
join us I want to thank n darsh uh she
was a Kyro coborn uh human rights
activist she's she grew up as a Muslim
she knows everything about Sharia all
the conditions
and sometimes it's well always it's
important to have uh Someone who lived
under that to speak about it and not
just read it in the books not read it
from um biased professors at
universities and from now on let me just
introduce I'm I'm done talking uh but
let me introduce uh Miss Nani Darwish
our
speaker thank you so much my
pleasure it's a real pleasure to be here
I want to thank the Temple University
and Temple University purpose for
inviting me and also for young American
foundation for sponsoring me to speak in
many
universities I want to start by uh
talking about what's happening in Egypt
right
now
um we've all seen the scenes at T
square and we've seen
the this revolution that's budding
everywhere in the Middle
East can you hear me
well and we all had mixed feelings I had
a lot of mixed feelings of Hope of I was
in prayers for my people my culture of
origin I felt extremely hopeful and I
wept I cried
I I just wanted to wish uh the Egyptian
people and the Arab people in general
the best I felt their
suffering I felt their pain because I
come from the same culture and I know
exactly what they what they
want but I wasn't very
optimistic because I have not seen signs
that say separation of musque and State
I didn't hear women walking and marching
demanding their freedom under the law
equality under the law the writers
wanted Freedom
democracy but not many really understand
what freedom and democracy
meant 75% of Egyptians when asked in a
survey a very recent survey
do you want to live under Sharia and the
75% wanted to live under
Sharia how can they live under
Sharia and at the same time want freedom
and democracy and
equality it's it they don't mix they
don't go together so there is a
gap there's a gap in the thinking of the
Middle East people about what is
democracy
and their love of their religion and
there is there has to be some
reconciliation and they have not yet
reach that
extent um there was a march by about two
300 young women University girls in tah
Square this March n March
9th they wanted to have a million woman
March
but only 200 appeared in t square and
here are the articles about
it this was not published anywhere or
talked about in our in uh American Media
what happened to these 20 200
girls 20 of their leaders were arrested
in Egypt they they accused them of being
being
prostitutes and they had to undergo go a
virginity test to prove they are not
prostitutes that's what happened to the
few girls who wanted to March
demanding equality under the law for
women can we have a uh equality in this
kind of circumstances a this is after
the re
ution 20 girls were arrested for daring
to
criticize the system that's not giving
them
equality and what I heard that when I
when I see these articles when I see
when I see these girls fighting for
their basic
rights I
can't I can't stop by really thanking
God for me
being here in
America being part of this country I
cherish the freedoms that America has
given
me and I remember my first day in
America on the job when I started my
first job in America as a new immigrant
I was reading every
everything I wanted to learn more about
this country and then on the corridor of
the
of the job I was I started there was a
sign so I went to read it and the sign
said this institution does not
discriminate against for hiring based on
gender race national origin or
religion and to American people if they
read this kind of sign they take it for
granted of course of course there's no
discrimination but for somebody who came
from from
Sharia it was nothing short of a
miracle I was in
awe to read a sign like that equating me
with a man in my
rights no discrimination based on gender
on
religious uh on your religious
background because where I came from you
are discriminated against based on your
gender legally under the law
on your what religion you
follow and I was just thankful I thank
God every day for being in this
country I just want to give you a short
uh little bit about my
background I was born and raised as a
Muslim in Cairo Egypt and I grew up as a
child in the 50s in the Gaza
Strip My Father headed the Egyptian mil
Military
Intelligence in
Gaza and he was assigned by gal Abdul
Naser the president of Egypt at that
time to destroy
Israel and Egypt at that time ruled
Gaza my father started the FID
operations against Israel the word fidi
means men who want to
self-sacrifice that's a
FID so these FID used to cross the
border and cause a lot of damage death
destruction inside
Israel and they were considered
Heroes uh they caused a lot of uh
problems for
Israel and Israel wanted to
retaliate they tried to stop the uh
uh this uh I don't know what's this
noise but I hope you can hear
me I attended Gaza elementary schools
and I learned hatred Vengeance
retaliation peace was never mentioned as
an objective it was not mentioned at all
it was not a value that we talked about
the only value we talked about
was Jihad martyrdom killing Jews throw
throwing them in the sea that's all we
talked about the victimhood status was
very important we are
victims because if we're not victims
then why fight the Jihad
Wars
why why do anything against our enemies
so being victims we were spoonfed the
idea of
victimhood they filled our hearts with
fear of Jews for example I never saw
Jews as a child but we were told Jews
would love to kill you as a they love to
kill Arab
children when you're a child and you
hear something like that hatred becomes
easy terrorism becomes acceptable who
wouldn't want to terrorize a monster
they were monsters who wanted to kill us
then good let's terrorize them let's
send terrorists to blow them
up it was not only good it was
honorable so that's how that's why we
celebrate when somebody goes in a in a
Jewish school and blow it up that's
good or go into a Jewish Home and blow
them up they they want to kill us that's
how we
felt
and my father was killed
eventually in this jihadist operations
against Israel I was eight years old I
lived all my
childhood inside the Arab Israeli
conflict that's what
I live every minute of my day the
bombing in
Gaza the the schools that's all we
talked
about the politicians that's all they
talked about the Friday prayers in the
MOs that's all they talked about the
media the cartoons
everything we were totally
indoctrinated with this kind of hate and
propaganda after after my father
died I went we went moved back to
Cairo
and uh he was a Shahid people
came
there is no
microphone and then there is this noise
so I don't
know closer yeah move closer and
alel the president of Egypt came to our
home to pay condolences because my
father was a very high ranking offic
official and I remember my mom made us
stand in line my siblings and I to greet
him and if I remember him and other
dignitaries they told us which one of
you kids will avenge your father's Blood
by killing
Jews I felt very uncomfortable even
though I was only eight it made me feel
so
uncomfortable that I am expected to do
exactly what my father did kill Jews I
just didn't want to do anything like
that and I looked at my siblings and
none of us answered we were
speechless but it left me with a feeling
that if I really loved my father that I
must kill Jews it left me with a feeling
that I'll be if I don't want to hate
Jews and want to kill them
then something is wrong with me I'm I'm
not loyal enough to my
father it's it and this this stayed with
me until today and that's why I still
remember that
question and now many Arabs today blame
today's worldwide Islamic
terrorism on the occupation of the West
Bank of
Gaza but what about the the terrorism
that happened against Israel and that
was before the occupation of the West
Bank and Gaza there was terrorism before
all of that it's not because of the
occupation of the west west bank and
Gaza I lived for 30 years of my life
under Islamic
law in OB in oppressive dictatorships
and police
States I witnessed honor killing of
girls female genital
mutilation
97% of my mother's
generation had undergone this operation
including my own
mother
I I witnessed oppression of
women I never linked it to Islam I never
linked all of that to Shar I thought
this is this is God's
will
I grew up hearing cursing cursing of
Jews
non-muslims from our religious leaders
in
mosques our religious leaders every
Friday at the end of every Friday
prayers they ended their prayer with
something like that may God destroy the
Jews and the infidels the enemies of
Allah we are not to befriend them we are
not to to take to to make any treaties
with them may Allah orphan their
children may Allah uh kill uh you know
orphan their W uh
wives and believe it or not if you grow
up with this kind of prayers cursing
prayers from so-called religious leaders
it can feel and sound
normal and ho
I never doubted that this is not proper
from a religious
leader they know better who am I to
judge my religious leader if they
curse but cursing is so common inside
mosques it happens on a daily basis
cursing the
non-muslims after
911 I learned that Muhammad the leader
of the 19 terrorists was from Kyo the
same city I came from he was from a
middle class or even a upper middle
class family
educated and I really felt bad that here
is my culture of origin attacking my
country here in America right
now and I called many people in Egypt I
wanted them to comfort me I wanted them
to tell me something is wrong with our
upbringing why are we have why do we
have thousands and thousands of young
men in the Muslim World ready to give up
their life just to kill
non-muslims we have brought up
Generations I am one of these people who
was brought up to value and to respect
and to honor people who want to kill
non-muslims especially
Jews I thought enough is
enough having all these airplanes come
and blow young men who are
educated have been so indoctrinated to
you know uh fly airplanes into buildings
this has reached the level of
insanity I called at least eight people
in in Egypt many of them friends and
many of them
family each and every one of them told
me the same thing how dare you say Arabs
did this don't you know the Jews did
it it's a Jews it's a Jewish conspiracy
the
Zionist I hung up the phone and I
wept it is a very lonely
feeling to feel that you you no longer
relate to your culture culture of
origin I loved my culture but I couldn't
relate to this denial of
reality I felt totally
disconnected from relating to to my my
people how can how can we accuse even
our worst enemy of something that we
know very well we have done
ourselves I mean
every religion any any faith should
discourage lying and accusing your enemy
of having done something that you know
you've done
yourself it's Arabs who did this it's
Muslims who did this why accuse the Jews
of doing it and it's so frustrating
because I don't see Jews or even our
media stand up and say this is a lie
make a big deal out of
it they're silent
where is CNN and fox after this you know
propaganda why don't they bring these
shakes and these you know politicians in
the Middle East and tell them you're
saying that the Jews did it can you have
can you prove it I don't see that it's
only if the Pope says something he's all
over the news it's only if an Israeli
politician s something he's he's he's
he's committed this horrible things but
when these my Muslim leaders are
indulged in awful lies about the Jewish
people in
America and suddenly our media just
ignores it I mean until recently you
know in the Haiti
earthquake everybody saying in the in
Arab media oh the Israel went there only
to harvest some some
organs this was an Arab TV I have the
clips it's on the internet the Israelis
went to Haiti not really to not really
to rescue the the Haitian people in the
earthquake they went to Haiti and this
is by reputable people on Arab TV only
to harvest organs to steal their
organs and now what's the latest
propaganda in Arab schools today the
latest propaganda
is you know who killed
yat he didn't die natural death he was
killed by the
Jews that is being taught in Arab
schools today guess what in 10 or 20
years it's going to be written in
history books in the whole Arab world
that Yas Arafat was killed by the
Jews and you have a new generation of
Arabs who want to avenge the death of Y
Arafat who by killing the Jews who
killed we are witnessing
today the lies of
tomorrow and we are silent and nobody's
talking about it in our
media only me and a few others who are
trying to uncover this propaganda that
is being taught to our children in Arab
schools today and it's going to be in
the history book of 54 Muslim countries
tomorrow it's going to be in the history
books just like Muhammad was killed by
the
Jews just like everything done by the
Jews why why all of this
propaganda it's not human it's not
humanly possible to live your whole a
whole culture
living on
propaganda that's what I discover my
culture was and it's not
it's not a
coincidence they really don't believe
that the Jewish people
deserve the truth justice or
Mercy the Jewish people are not human
they are the product of Apes pigs and
enemies of
Allah they don't and this is the Jewish
people it is such a
tragedy that this is not exposed
properly in the 21st century by the
media it's not properly responded
to and you have 1 billion people being
indoctrinated on a daily basis on lies
like that but when
I uh it's it's not just a tragedy it's a
disgrace it is a disgrace that today
there are cultur that are doing such
propaganda and the land of the free and
the home of the
pra the land of America is making people
like me who's exposing this horrific
propaganda a taboo to talk
about it's
scary I'm not saying anything that's a
lie when I say propaganda in the Middle
East is horrendous it's true you don't
have to believe me just go on the
internet and see what they're
saying uh and that's why I started
speaking and I I know why we're not
going to have democracy in the Middle
East 45 at least 45 Muslim countries
have signed a kairo declaration in
1991 stating that Sharia Islamic law
supersedes any other law
when it comes to human rights when it
comes to the laws of the of the
Land There is
uh the the constitution of of Egypt
today states that
Shar supersedes any other
law how many signed it how many
countries 45 Muslim count countries
signed the 1991 Cairo
declaration and guess what After the
revolution
tion nobody can take out this I this uh
statement from from the from
the from Egypt's
Constitution it's uh it's number two in
the in the constitution of Egypt el
el he's he he is trying to run for
president in Egypt he hit Ed hinted at
removing this uh uh I think it's item
two of the Egyptian article article two
of the Egyptian Revol uh Constitution he
hinted at removing it when he was
walking in the street after he hinted at
it rocks were thrown at
him no Muslim leader will
survive if he removes Shar as the base
of the law of any Muslim
country I'll tell you why why is that so
why can't a Muslim leader survive
because in
Sharia the job of a Muslim head of state
is already
stated number one of the job of any
Muslim head of state is to preserve Shar
as the law of the
land and never accept
novelty they call it an Arabic B never
accept any novel
ideas this is already his job as a
Muslim head of state is already
established under under Islamic
law number two in what a Muslim head of
state must
do it's a Muslim head of state must must
conduct jihadist
operations against non-muslim countries
Jews Christians and
pagans job number two of every Muslim
head of state this
the no that's Sharia
books that's Sharia books Sharia the K
the Kyo declaration states only that we
must follow Shar it's suedes any other
law but the Sharia books state that a
Muslim head of state must do Jihad and
then it defines what Jihad
is so a lot of people after
91 uh on American TV they were defining
Jihad
as an inner struggle self analysis
something like that's really like
Buddhist it it do
sound Islamic at all and I'm not going
to tell you my opinion of what Jihad is
but according and by the way I like the
inner struggle interpretation of
jihad but I've never heard it in the
Middle
East I lived for 30 years of my life in
the Middle East I never heard that Jihad
is just an inner struggle and
self-analysis cuz we're not very good at
doing
that here's the definition of jihad from
the Shar
books to war against
non-muslims to establish the
religion there are many
other
uh many other statements like that in
Shar book for example fleeing from the
Jihad Wars or or fleeing from combat
with unbelievers is an
enormity that will that's punishable by
them and all of all of the statements
I'm saying now I have the references
page number and everything in the Sharia
books since the Jihad is the main duty
of a Muslim Head of
State uh also the you know I'll give you
another quotation because there are so
many quotations in the Shar that tells
the Muslim head of state to never make
peace with non-muslim countries and
treat them always as
inferior here the Khalifa fights all
other people until they become
Muslim when non-muslims are in their own
country in which case Jihad is a
communal obligation upon Muslims each
year he who who provides the
equipment for a soldier in Jihad has
himself performed Jihad so all the
people who are donating the money for
elad and Hamas and healah from Arabian
Peninsula all this oil money that's
going there they will never survive
without that money by the way they are
doing Jihad themselves according to the
Shar what the West needs to understand
is that Jihad the Jihad
Doctrine challenges the sovereignty of
non-muslim
countries there is Islam does not
recognize America as a sovereign
state it doesn't recognize any
non-muslim country Europe as a sovereign
state it's open to Jihad it's G
har we must fight it because it's not a
legit State because it's not a Muslim
state that is
Jihad and until we understand what Jihad
means really we're in
trouble theh there is another law here
the Khalifa makes War upon Jews
Christians and zosan until they become
Muslims or else pay the non-muslim PO
tax while being
belittled while being belittled while
you are you you are demeaning them they
have to feel
demeaned and by the way this is from
from their books I'm not if anybody uh I
you know there's anybody who wants to
challenge me I'll give you the law
number
Muslims I mean it's repeated over and
over I'll take questions at the end as
long as you want the it's this duty of
jihad is is all over Muslim
scriptures it's not just what once or
twice or three times it's the main
topic of
Islam even when the Khalifa appoints a
ruler on a region that's in an area
that's border ERS are adjacent to enemy
Land by enemy land they mean non-muslim
land he has the right by himself to
undertake Jihad against these enemies
dividing The Spoils of battle among
combatants and deserving
recipients so the property of non-muslim
lands doesn't belong to them their
property after you subdue them and you
go into war with them their property is
yours it's
legitimate and so this is what we're
dealing with and you wonder why s Sadat
was
killed when Sadat signed the peace
treaty with Israel and meant it he was
violating his duty as a Muslim head of
state when he signed it he told his
Confidant I know I'm signing my death
death
warrant why because he is violating
sharw as a
Muslim and that's why I said that
Wasim and not a lot of people understand
that
uh Muslim Muslim he of States this is
very important to understand why Muslim
heads of States they all when they talk
to their people they say one thing when
they talk to the West they say something
else because they're in a
quagmire if they please the
International Community they have
violated Shar law and if they talk to
their people about Jihad which what
their people want to hear they are
violating international
law so it's a quagmire it's not that
they are evil as much as they are they
can be killed their life is on the line
um and that's exactly what happened to
sadad there is also a Sharia law that
that is uh really against our
constitution and it says it's obligatory
to obey the Khalifa even if he's
unjust so a Muslim head of States as
long as he rules under
Sharia as long as he Rules by the Shar
he must be obeyed even if he is unjust
and you wonder why there are the Saddam
husin of the Middle East and the kazis
of the Middle East they are ring by Shar
and you cannot tell them why they are
unjust you have to obey Rebellion
against the Khalifa even if he's unjust
is an enormity I'm I'm reading I'm
reading from Sharia
books is considered a an enormous with
the death
penalty under Sharia law and this is
something that's totally against our
constitution and I don't know I really
don't understand people like uh Rel
religious leaders here Muslim in America
who are saying oh but Sharia is so
compatible with our
constitution it's so there's no we we
we're just like apple pie and a you know
American why do you say this about
Sharia they tell me okay here I'll I'll
give you a
law the Khalifa is allowed to hold
office through seizure of power meaning
through Force law number 0
25.4 musim
americ yeah here it is a law that says
that you know let's not I was married a
very hardworking
mus let's let's let's get into a
discussion of questions later let's see
we'll we'll we'll talk later all
the by the way I'm I I love Muslim
people my my the people it's not the
people it's the IDE is this is the law
what
I what I object to is the
law if a Muslim head of state let's say
in an Arab country if you look at the
history of every every Muslim head of
state you'll find that they came to
power through
audita assassinating of a previous
president why is that and and he becomes
accepted as a leader later people clap
and and cheer for him after why we think
it's it's done just because the people
are are ignorant or Not educated enough
to understand that this is not uh this
is not a proper way to come to to power
through seizure of power like that to
audita it's allowed under the
law the people are not stupid they're
following their
laws and that is why there is no
political
stability elections are never
mentioned in in the in Sharia actually
there is a lot of Muslim leaders who say
democracy as it's practiced in the West
is
anti-islamic and I'm not the one who
says
so so a Muslim head of state also is
exempt from being charged with serious
crimes such as murder adultery robbery
theft and
drinking so all these Muslim have of
States who are who have to drink wine
and and they kill their people they
murder murder they rob their their their
people they put the money in the Swiss
bank accounts look what did with the
money that he had for his people look at
what yes it's allowed he they will never
be
charged under the laws of
sharia they are not to be charged so we
we really cannot blame it on these
dictators that they are living like that
they have to rule by
Sharia they have they cannot be charged
with with the same crimes they are
prosecuted the people with and at the
same time it's an
enormity to uh to uh write or rebel
against
them all cannot survive in a
democracy
it's it's not it's it's totally against
our system of the
democracy because Sharia really is a
dictator friendly
law and it uh it's
amazing many Arabs blame the existence
of their dictatorships on America oh
it's America's foreign
policy that's you're preserving our
dictators well when when did they ever
have a
democracy never democracy and freedom
was
never the State of Affair in in the in
Islamic history
actually America deals with whoever the
leader
is whether it's they deal with certain
leaders because they want a stable
government that's all they want America
all they want is a stable government to
deal
with and what about the dictators like
the Syrian dictator uh uh uh Libyan
dictator America is not their friends
but they're still dictators so you can't
say that America's foreign policy is the
is the cause of
dictatorships that's the system that
they have there we befriend some we
don't be friendome and that is uh
blaming and finger pointing is is the
only solution and we should never accept
the
claim that uh uh that American foreign
policy perpetuates dictatorships it's
the State of Affairs in the political
systems of Arab
countries that claim also uh that uh was
was promoted but the Soviet Union during
the Cold War but even though this is
absurd many
westerners uh bought this claim that
America's foreign policy is is behind
dictatorships they don't understand
saying that the reason for all of this
anger which has been building in the
culture of jihad since the since the
seventh
century Muslims must justify
Jihad which is against international law
Jihad is the violation of the supremacy
and and sovereignty of non-muslim
countries and to justify Jihad you have
to blame the cultures that you want to
uh
conquer so we have to blame them for our
dictators we have to blame them for
occupation we have to blame them for I'm
a
victim and that's the best way to fight
them under the guise of being the victim
when in reality the West is now the
victim Europe is is now the
victim how many Christians can practice
their religion in the Middle East
without being
killed they they are writing because
somebody burned the Quran the the bibles
are being burned on a daily basis in the
Muslim World churches are being burned
on a daily basis in
Egypt every Christmas there is a church
where they have driveby shooting on the
people when they're Le leaving leaving
the the churches every in in Cairo the
homes of the Christians in Egypt are
being
burned this is almost a weekly
event where are the rights by the
Christians in the
west it's not even mentioned in the
media
here uh Islam is the only religion on
Earth that
legally kills those who leave
it it's against the law the laws of
sharia in all the schools of sharia no
exception there are four schools of sun
Sharia and there is two schools of shi
sh
Sharia all of them agree that a Muslim
who leaves his or her religion must be
killed I am now on a death
sentence under
Sharia and I'm still told you're not
supposed to speak about
it don't
talk you have to repress your your your
rights because you're going to offend
somebody I have no wish to offend
anybody
it's not something I'm proud of to speak
about my culture of origin but the truth
has to come
out nobody wants to criticize a religion
any
religion let alone my religion of origin
some of the nicest people I meet are
Muslims I'm not speaking about the
Muslim people I'm speaking about a legal
system a horrific barbaric legal system
called
Sharia that's oppressing
people nobody in the west myself wants
to criticize religion I don't want to
criticize uh you know uh
Hinduism I don't want to criticize
Judaism Christianity or even Islam but
if a
religion expands itself so
much to become a state
if a religion expands
Itself by itself so much to demand a
legal
system call it
Shar and under that legal system they
want to put me to death because I don't
want to follow a
religion then
that that religion has expanded itself
so
much that it's no longer protect Ed not
to be
criticized from
criticism that religion has expanded
itself so much that it has a military
institution called
Jihad that violates the sovereignty of
every non-muslim country you are not
sovereign for Muslim country to protect
yourself you should not protect yourself
from Islam and that's the that's the
purpose of of jihad the jihadist
obligation that's why
you're land of
War if a religion has expanded itself so
much to become a state and a legal
system and a military
institution then that
religion has opened itself to criticism
amen and that
religion it's my duty and the duty of
every free n Muslim country to criticize
that religion because it's no longer a
religion it's a
state it's a constitutional state that
violates the rights of people who don't
follow
it and even people who
follow and that's why I'm speaking I'm
not speaking because I just want he
hazly to criticize
Islam who cares I have better things to
do but I cannot let myself be under a
death sentence and stay
[Applause]
silent even there are many people in
Egypt today who are in
hiding because they don't want to
practice Islam i i in touch with many of
them and they are living a horrendous
life some Christians who convert to
Islam and regret it in Egypt I want to
go back to
Christianity do you know that the law in
Egypt today today prevents them from
doing that it's against the law to leave
Islam even if you were a Christian you
fell in love with a Muslim girl you
changed your religion to Islam to marry
her and the marriage didn't work out now
I want to go back to to to Christianity
and marry
my my you know a Christian woman I can't
you can't it's against the law in Egypt
today this is the these are facts what
I'm talking about are facts it's against
the law there is a a man his name is
Muhammad uh
hegazi he's a Muslim man who wanted to
convert to Christianity for the first
time in Egyptian
history he challenged the laws his story
became International so nobody wants to
kill him but he got he gets beaten a lot
on the street he
wants to convert to Islam to
Christianity
legally because it's your religion is by
by you know by force in Egypt you're
you're born and your birth certificate
St
Muslim Christian
Muslim he wanted to have the right in
Egypt to call name he his wife was
pregnant he wanted that his
son on his birth certificate to have it
Stand
Christian and to call his son a
Christian
name he could not under Egyptian laws
today it's illegal under Sharia it's
illegal in almost all Muslim countries
including turkey a lot of people think
turkey oh turkey is so
free you know you can't you can't
legally leave your religion in
Turkey it's against the laws of the
country let alone Sharia guess what
Hamed heistan is a Muslim legally by
force against his father's wishes and
he's in
hiding that's what I'm talking
about the rights of these
people and uh
under under Sharia law there are three
murders where a Muslim Is Forgiven
for three anybody any Muslim on the
street in the Middle East three murders
and it says here I'm I'm reading it from
the Sharia
books under Shar a Muslim is Forgiven
for killing an
apostate killing an adulterer who's
usually an
adulteress and killing a highway
robber what does that mean when you
forgive a Muslim for killing an apostate
is allowed it means vigilante Street
Justice is allowed on the street and you
wonder why they walk in the streets burn
and kill and get
angry you wonder why because it's
allowed under the
law it's allowed under the
law so I if if I walk in Egypt I cannot
visit the Middle East by the way because
I'd be killed if I walk in the streets
of Egypt now I'm not just afraid of the
government anybody can kill
me and he'll be defended he'll be
defended by these laws some people will
say you're lying you're exaggerating in
1991 there was a
journalist um an Egyptian journalist who
was uh speak against certain uh uh
rights for uh oppression of
women uh and um he was accused of being
an apostate he was not he said I'm not
an apostate I'm just speaking against
Shar he was criticizing Sharia heavily
and just by merely criticizing Sharia he
was accused of apostasy he was gunned
down in front of his home in front of
his
son when he in the trial of his murder
murderer was
defended by none other than the shikh of
Alazar the top Muslim Authority in Cairo
the grand shikh of Alazar went to his
trial and said since our government does
not does
not kill those who are called
apostates then anyone on the street can
kill them it's
okay the man who killed him never at the
end write it down I can confirm that in
Iraq the same is true
yeah the man who killed that journalist
was
never uh put in
jail because of the laws of Shar that
want to bring here in
America so